I'm not agreeing about this honestly
um because
the fact you as he said the fact you
slept with multiple men or whatever how
many they are doesn't really it depends
like was you actually in a relationship
with him oh it was just occasional thing
you know and I also accept occasional
stuff like because you know like if you
match someone and you you know you just
want to enjoy your day there's nothing
wrong with that and that's honestly no
one hello a man to tell me are less
vulnerable than someone else that had
sex just once well it's not like it's
not who you as my body gonna be the same
body and myself gonna be the same person
after 10 20 men it wouldn't change